selfish elves a Santa kidnapping and a
candy fueled creeper we love Elf but
there are a few things you won't be able
to ignore next time you watch it
at its heart elf is a classic Fish Out
of Water comedy but with the added twist
being that the fish Buddy the elf
doesn't fit in back in the water either
the movie's opening scenes show us some
great physical comedy as the six foot
three Will Ferrell squeezes himself into
elf-sized showers and beds but here's
the thing why don't the elves just you
know make him a bed one of the things
that makes the movie feel heartwarming
and Christmasy is that the other elves
up at Santa's Workshop are generally
pretty nice to Buddy they even take time
to reassure him that he's got his own
special talents when he starts to feel
like he doesn't fit in and even if they
get frustrated behind his back it's
clear that they care about him so why in
the 30 years that he's been there
haven't they made the slightest
adjustment to their housing situation so
that he's not destroying his spine every
night it's not like it would take them
that long building things is literally
all the elves do and a king-sized bed
frame and Mattress surely wouldn't take
as much time to Cobble together others
say building a PlayStation 5 from
scratch he's not even the only one there
who needs human-sized furniture since
Santa Claus also lives there and has
been doing so for about 1500 years even
if the elves aren't the ones who made
his furniture just order another
mattress and put it on the floor it's
not great but it's better than sleeping
with all your limbs hanging off the bed
the odd thing about Buddy the elf is
that he never seems to notice that he's
roughly three times taller than everyone
he knows well almost everyone The Only
Exception is Santa Claus but he's still
taller than Santa but not to the extent
that it is with the other elves if
anything buddy should probably assume
that he's a Santa or at least some other
kind of human the only reason the buddy
thinks he's an elf at all is that after
accidentally kidnapping him when buddy
was an infant Santa pulls the very
unsanta-like move of keeping him and
handing him off to the elves this by the
way is not what you should do if you
ever find a Baby Buddies naivete is at
the core of the film but there's a fine
line between his Earnest good-natured
belief that a random Diner really did
perfect the world's best cup of coffee
and the kind of oblivious ignorance of
just not being able to put simple Clues
together
you'd think that if you can figure out
how to build 85 etch-a-sketches in a
single day you'd be a little bit better
at putting things together
sea of swirly twirly gumdrops and then I
walked through the Lincoln Tunnel this
is going to sound pretty nitpicky for a
movie where we're willing to accept that
Santa Claus can fly around the world in
a single night giving all the good
children presents but the fact that
buddy Walks from the North Pole to
Manhattan is a little ridiculous there
are a lot of reasons for that primarily
the fact that it's a straight shot of
about 3 400 miles from Santa's Workshop
to Manhattan even if we're willing to
accept that the iceberg he floats off on
takes him down to Canada that still
leaves him in the Nunavut with 2 900
miles left to go we'll give you that his
elf clothes are magical and able to keep
him warm at the North Pole and Below but
still no matter how hyped up he is on
maple syrup and candy canes that's a
long and potentially or let's be real
here almost certainly fatal Journey for
someone who's completely unprepared for
it now here's why this isn't as much of
a nitpick as it seems like the scene
sticks out because this is a movie with
Santa in it the guy has a magic flying
sleigh that can cover 212 million miles
in a single night sure he's a busy guy
around the holidays but are we really
meant to believe that Santa Claus can't
take 0.4 seconds out of his day so that
he doesn't have to deal with the singing
penguin finding a dead body in the candy
cane Forest after the spring thaw you
like sugar huh is there sugar and syrup
yes then yes
one of the biggest sources of Comedy
throughout elf is Buddy's ridiculously
candy-centric diet after all he hails
from a land of Christmas cheer that was
inspired by the rank and bass
stop-motion specials of the 60s so he
grew up on a steady diet of candy canes
and describes the North Poles for food
groups as candy candy canes candy corns
and syrup of course that means buddy
should be straight up dead you probably
figured this out for yourself in the
days after Halloween when you were a kid
but a diet that consists entirely of
candy isn't just unhealthy it's also a
great way to get type 2 diabetes sure
you could explain it away by saying that
all the candy at the North Pole is
suffused with Christmas magic that makes
it delicious and nutritious but after he
comes to New York but it keeps up his
standard habits drowning a plate of
spaghetti with an entire bottle of maple
syrup and washing it down by slamming an
entire 2-liter bottle of Coca-Cola in
fact the few things we see him eat in
the movie that aren't handy are a bottle
of booze and a Jar full of cotton balls
fun fact in real life those cotton balls
were actually cotton candy if you need
any evidence that wolfing down that much
sugar was a bad idea look no further
than Will Ferrell himself in interviews
about the film since its release he's
talked about how he lost sleep while the
movie was being filmed thanks to the
constant sugar intake multiply that by
30 plus years worth of sugar-coated
meals and you've got health problems
that go Way Beyond a little insomnia and
into the territory of having your heart
explode while chugging maple syrup did
you sleep okay last night great I got a
full 40 minutes
just five years away from Iron Man John
Favreau was the man who directed elf and
he even has a small part as the Hobbes
family's friendly physician he also
provides the voice of the North Pole's
resident narwhal bye buddy hope you find
your dad and while we're talking about
that Rose doctor we'd be remiss if we
didn't cover what might be the worst
medical decision ever committed to film
after performing a DNA test to confirm
that yes buddy is in fact Walter's
biological son the doctor advises Walter
to take Buddy home to meet his wife and
son in hopes that he'll eventually come
to terms with the situation and drop the
whole elf thing and move on obviously
that all works out for buddy in the Hops
family but by any measure the system
truly terrible advice both Walter and
the doctor are operating under the
assumption that buddy is extremely
delusional any medical professional
worth its stethoscope would most likely
suggest that they get buddy some
immediate treatment psychiatric or
otherwise before his disc connect with
reality leads to more violence that's
right more violence the scene with the
blood test happens directly after Walter
Bales buddy out of jail after he
assaults a department store Santa at
Gimbels in other words the doctor is
confronted with a delusional man with a
very recent history of violence and his
solution to this problem is to take him
home to your wife and kid here's hoping
the first thing the Hobbs family does
after the credits roll is get themselves
a new general practitioner your father
yeah he's on the naughty list
the driving conflict of elf is that
Walter Hobbs but he's long-lost human
father has landed himself squarely on
the naughty list the reason well in
addition to just being a fairly
unpleasant person and all those murders
he did in The Godfather Walter has been
neglecting his family and focusing too
much on his work this is the plot to
plenty of Christmas movies about
learning how to love your family more
effectively under the boot heel of
consumerism but there's something
different about Walter's story he's
genuinely terrible at his job
normally the person in this kind of plot
who's obsessing over their work is at
least successful in that Arena which
makes it more effective when they have
to choose what's really important
Walter's got plenty of money that
apartment at Central Park West doesn't
come cheap but as far as the work goes
he's hardly a success his company's
floundering and their downturn is a
direct result of decisions that he made
or rather due to decisions that he
didn't make despite filling the role of
the workaholic who spends too much time
at the office Walter doesn't actually
seem to care about anything that he's
doing at work to the point of approving
a proof of a book that was missing two
pages even the most inept employee would
notice if he was initialing two gigantic
blank pages so the simple fact is that
Walter just doesn't care that raises a
pretty Grim question though if he's
neglecting his family for work but he's
not actually doing any work is he just
sitting there taking as much time away
from his wife and son as he can so that
he can stare off into space and
contemplate Oblivion that is heart I
like it
I I like it the major drama at the
climax of the film centers around
whether Santa's sleigh is going to be
able to fly without the engine that's
been keeping it going all these years
see without the engine the sleigh has to
rely entirely on the magic of Christmas
cheer to power it around the world and
according to the clausometer there's
just not enough Christmas spirit to do
the job but that doesn't make sense this
is a world where Santa Claus is 100
actually factually real with a toy
factory at the North Pole staffed by
cheerful singing elves a talking snowman
and everything that goes along with him
he brings presents to The Good Children
all over the world which means that
there's no disillusionment or
disappointment from kids who didn't get
what they wanted on Christmas morning we
also know from the movie that getting a
present does in fact increase your
Christmas spirit as Michael Walter's
other son boosts the clausometer a
little bit when he gets the skateboard
he's always wanted so if Santa and the
elves have been doing their job and as
far as we know they have then there
should be more than enough Christmas
spirit to go around just from that let
alone all the general feel good
Sentiments of peace on Earth Goodwill
hot chocolate and so on
one of the things that makes elf such a
favorite around the holidays is that
it's an almost relentlessly cheerful
film without getting too sugary sweet
but he's spaghetti notwithstanding in
fact the closest it gets to anything
you'd call dark would be the depiction
of the Santa hating Central Park Rangers
at the end oh and that one part where
buddy commits felony assault on an
innocent man for the crime of dressing
up as Santa Claus but even if Buddy's
sudden temper is slightly out of
character that all makes perfect sense
in the context of the movie what happens
after however seems like a stretch since
the original gimbals Santa is no longer
available the toy Department's manager
has to fill in and frankly that's
ridiculous if you've ever been to Macy's
around Christmas time then you already
know that these stores take their Santa
set up very seriously it's a lot more
complicated than just one dude sitting
on a big chair asking kids what they
want for Christmas the gimbals we see in
the movie might not be as dedicated to
it as Macy's of course historically the
real life gimbals was Macy's competitor
until shutting down in 1987 with their
rivalry cementing itself into Christmas
movie history as a plot point in the
original Miracle on 34th Street still
the idea that a store that big wouldn't
have at least a couple of backup Santas
is somehow more difficult to believe
than the flying reindeer
Buddy's romance with Jovi a young woman
working as an alpha gimbals played in a
star-making turn by Zooey Deschanel ends
up being pretty sweet but it has a rocky
start most people don't wind up going on
dates with strangers who sneak up on
them in the shower no matter how nice
they are about your singing afterwards
considering that elf has a run time of
just over 90 minutes it makes sense that
things have to move pretty fast to get
everything wrapped up by the time the
credits roll still Jovi's awfully quick
to forgive buddy for creeping up on her
in the shower especially since the next
two interactions she has with him
involve him beating up the guy playing
Santa Claus and then telling her that
his tongue swells up around her and
asking if she wants to go eat food I
feel really warm when I am around you
the fact that she goes out with them at
all let alone ends up in happy elf and
matrimony after it's all said and done
as well it's a Christmas miracle the
weirdest part of all of this might be
one that Jovi would have no way of
knowing but that we in the audience can
Peg as what might be the only lie but he
tells in the whole movie when she asks
if he was spying on her in the shower he
replies I didn't know you're naked this
seems plausible given Buddy's naive
nature the thing is he definitely knew
she was in the shower and we actually
see buddy showering in an elf-sized tub
earlier in the movie of course he did
have his hat on at the time so maybe
elves are a rare class of never nudes oh
I'm sorry no I need you to be completely
undressed I am completely undressed
there are any number of ways to tell a
child that they are adopted though
perhaps no worse way than for them to
overhear it from two co-workers
bad-mouthing their Etch-a-Sketch
production output but he learns the hard
way that he's not an elf and while you
might reasonably expect him to come to
that conclusion after a decade or two
it's also not unreasonable to expect
Papa elf and Santa to have had that
conversation directly saving buddy a
bundle of unnecessary trauma Santa's
judgment in regards to the whole buddy
situation becomes even more suspect
considering the fact that he's
apparently had all the information
needed to reunite buddy with his father
for years it would be one thing if Buddy
were simply an anonymous orphan who
crawled into Santa's sack one year in
that case it would make a certain amount
of sense for Santa to take the human
baby in and raise it at the North Pole
but Santa also knows the name of Buddy's
mother Susan Wells the circumstances of
her death the name of his still living
father Walter Moss Walter's job and the
location of his office and the fact that
Walter is on the naughty list he only
reveals this information when his hand
is forced as buddy inadvertently
discovers the truth while it's hard to
hate on Santa Claus all of this points
to a serious lapse of judgment on the
big guy's part
the scene featuring Future Game of
Thrones star Peter Dinklage as Hotshot
children's book author miles Finch is
cringe inducing but purposely so Walter
has bribed miles to come into the office
and help his clueless in-house riders
with a new book pitch he's hoping this
pitch will be the thing that gets Walter
back in good with his boss and save his
job but before miles can get into his
potential storyline but he barges into
the meeting and mistakes the man for an
elf miles takes offense at Buddy's
sincere excitement to see a fellow elf
as a crack about his height and while he
tries to keep his cool eventually
Buddy's insults become too much to bear
miles runs across the boardroom table
and drop kicks him that all makes sense
even if in illustrating Buddy's
insensitivity the film itself gets a
little insensitive what doesn't make
much sense is how no one else in this
scene not Walter his writers or his
secretary does anything to break up the
fight as miles chokes buddy to the
ground and breaks every lighting fixture
in peace of glassware in the room along
the way they all just sit there
apparently Frozen in shock until the
scene ends with Walter angrily disowning
buddy
every year it seems that someone on the
internet discovers and is newly
horrified by the scene in which buddy
banished to The Greenway press mail room
for irritating Walter makes friends with
and accidentally gets day drunk with a
worker played by Mark Atchison as they
recline on a pair of rolling carts full
of padded envelopes declaring themselves
best friends mailroom guy as he is
credited laments the direction that his
life is taken he just goes with the flow
but now he needs to get out of the flow
I'm 26 years old I got nothing to show
you're young you're so young
Atchison was in fact 46 years old when
the film was released and while he may
appear relatively youthful for a 46 year
old he makes for an alarmingly craggy
gravel voiced 26 year old mailroom guy
works in a chaotic processing room with
no source of natural light he drinks
from a half pint of hard liquor on the
job and only has the job thanks to a
prison work release program so the
impact of the gag makes for a worthy
suspension of disbelief
[Music]